certain cultures of men that cheat more  than others or do you think it's all men  I don't think it's so this whole I I  think that certain types of men cheat  more so like if you're gonna date an NBA  player or  um and like you know versus like the  computer nerd I feel like the commute  computer nerd is less likely to do it  that probably boes down to options  though again  like the NBA player is going to have mad  options so it's a lot more difficult for  him not to cheat words  like you get these guys that say I've  never cheated in my life I've never  stepped out by his life  you actually can't go and draw another  girl but like for the guys that have  girls throwing themselves at him it's a  lot more difficult